[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain episodes 1 and 2 of a thai
television series called bad genius
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the first scene shows us the final round
of a junior high school scrabble
competition a girl named lynn is
competing against soros from a rival
school lynn's father veat and the
school's principal of a prestigious
school are in the audience watching the
game the principal promises to admit
lynn to her school with a full
scholarship if she wins the match her
competitor soros seems to be struggling
in the last round so he deliberately
drops an eraser his mentor picks it up
and gives it back to him lin notices
that the man changes the eraser with one
that has the answers written on it she
catches soros cheating and quietly calls
him out for it but doesn't tell the
judges for her final word she writes
cheater and wins the match the crowd
applauds and cheers and lin is given
certificates of honor during dinner at
night her father vet asks her if she
likes her new school lynn boasts about
the computers rooms with ac and the
library of the school she adds that her
favorite place is the music room that
has a grand piano which she can play
during lunch veat inquires if she made
any friends and lynn awkwardly says she
has one day while playing piano in
school lynne is approached by her
classmate named grace she asks for lin's
help to practice a song for the school
play lin plays the piano while grace
sings but they stop when grace is
off-key on certain parts she is sad
because she might not get a role in the
play and claims that it is her dream to
be in one lin then asks her to listen to
the keys carefully and go along with
them after a little practice grace gets
the key right and is overjoyed before
lynn leaves grace asks her to wait for
her outside the music room so they can
meet after her audition the audition
goes great but grace comes out of the
room with teary eyes it turns out that
according to the new rule students who
want to be in the school play must have
a gpa above 3.25
when grace complains that she has never
had a gpa that high lin offers to tutor
her for the next few days they study
together in the library their math
teacher sophon tutors students outside
of school one day grace who is also in
his private class brings a sample
question paper that sophon has provided
lynn notices the questions are more
difficult than the ones he teaches in
class but practices them anyway a few
weeks later they are in their midterm
math exam for the first few minutes lynn
answers all the questions with no
difficulty but then she notices most of
the questions are identical to the
practice questions that grace had it is
clear to lynn that sophon had been
providing test questions to the students
who pay him for coaching outside school
she writes all the answers on an eraser
puts it inside her shoe and kicks it
back to grace's desk grace gets the
answers and copies them all down when
the results are out grace is overjoyed
to get the highest marks she ever has
but since the girls score the same
sophon is suspicious of them he warns
the girls to be careful because if he
finds them cheating he will not go easy
on them after he leaves grace invites
lynn for dinner at her boyfriend pat's
house in the evening they go to meet pat
in a lavish restaurant right next to his
apartment he turns out to be a wealthy
kid who is lazy and gets bad grades
after he treats the girls to dinner he
asks lynn to help him in the exam just
as she did with grace the girls are
surprised when pat offers lynn a lot of
money to help him his father has
promised to buy him a sports car if he
doesn't fail hence he desperately needs
her help however lynn doesn't want to
risk getting caught so she rejects the
offer she returns home at night to her
father vite eating noodles lin asks him
to be more careful with his diet and
goes to her room a while later she hears
him talk to someone on the phone about a
loan lynn confronts him about this and
finds out that he has borrowed money
from his brother to pay for lynn's
tuition the principal promised to
provide her full scholarship if she wins
the scrabble contest but because of a
budget issue lynn and a guy from her
school have to share the scholarship
meaning they will still have to pay half
of the fee each semester lynn knows that
her father cannot afford such prices and
says she will transfer back to her old
school but veet insists she will get
more opportunities in this new one now
to get a full scholarship lin will have
to compete with the other guy and prove
she is better the following day at
school lynn sees a little kid trying
hard to get a balloon on the ceiling she
tries to help him but cannot reach it
just then a guy named bank arrives and
helps them the kids call them a nice
couple making the two of them flustered
after the kid walks away lynn introduces
herself and finds out bank is actually
the guy she is sharing her scholarship
with she asks him if they can still be
friends but bank rejects her saying that
they're competitors in the following
scene lynn is back at pat's apartment
building to pay for her father's loans
and her tuition fee she finally agrees
to help him in grace cheat in the exam
her condition is that the couple will
only get three-fourths of the answers so
their teacher won't suspect them pat
accepts the deal the following scene is
their final exam of the first semester
and lynn has to help both grace and pat
alongside completing the test herself
like earlier she starts writing on an
eraser but stops when sophon walks
towards her he keeps an eye on her
throughout the exam and eventually
notices her writing on the eraser the
man snatches the eraser and is surprised
to see you're slipping exam papers to
students written on it he realizes she
knows his secret and tries to reason
with her but lynn hands him her answer
sheet and walks out of the classroom
sophon asks the others to continue and
follows lin lin remains adamant about
telling the principal as sophon tries to
convince her otherwise he even threatens
to tell the principal that she let grace
cheat from her paper but lynn fires back
saying that grace got good grades
because of his tuition classes as she
walks away sophon notices her hand is
inside her pocket and asks her if she is
recording their conversation
when she brings her phone out it is
revealed she has been on a call with the
principal this whole time a distressed
sofan heads back to the classroom as the
students get out grace and pat thank lin
as everything went according to their
plan it turns out that they had planned
the whole scenario beforehand because of
sofon's tuition papers lin could
complete her paper in just a few minutes
she also marked the answers on her
question paper and asked grace to
exchange it with hers while she
distracts sophon after that grace wrote
the answers on an eraser and gave them
to pat and all three of them did great
on the exam moreover lynn had changed
pat's name on her phone to the
principals that way she wouldn't get so
fun kicked out but still intimidate him
however later at night she gets numerous
messages on a group chat saying that
sophon has been fired from the school
lin rushes to pat's apartment again and
asks him how did the principal know pat
replies that he had recorded the phone
call and sent it to the real principal
because he believed sofon could create
trouble for them in the future lynn
isn't happy about the move but dismisses
the matter the next day at school she
again meets the same kid and finds out
he is sophon's son who has been kicked
out of the school because of his
father's deeds lynn guiltily watches
them go down the elevator in the
following scene we are taken to bank's
laundry shop he lives with his single
mother who is obsessed with lottery
tickets she has severe back problems but
because of their financial condition
they cannot afford to get it treated
later in school bank and lynn are called
by the principal because she wants them
to take part in a tv show quiz
competition neither of them are willing
to partner up but the principal
convinces them by declaring that this
competition will decide who is going to
get the next term scholarship among the
two hence even if they are partnered the
one who gives the most answers will get
the scholarship the very next day they
are on the set of the reality show the
quiz starts and bank gives the first
right answer followed by lin the duo
leads by two points but is soon
overtaken when bank hastily says the
wrong answer lin suggests that he think
and discuss with her before throwing
random answers if they go against each
other they might lose the quiz so for
the last question they discuss the
answer the other team answers first but
gets the answer wrong at last lin cites
the right one and wins the competition
the following day they are at the
principal's office where she tells them
that lynn has won a full scholarship she
asks bank to apply for a scholarship
again next semester and dismisses them
after the meeting lin tries to comfort
bank but he ignores her later we see him
take his mother to a government hospital
where they have to wait for hours for
her turn he also tells her that he
didn't get the scholarship but the
mother quickly hides her disappointment
and assures him she will collect the
money before the next semester one day
at school pat calls lynn into the
computer lab and asks her if she will
stop helping him cheat now that she
doesn't have to pay for tuition he
laughs at her when the girl says she
doesn't need his money anymore according
to pat the school will still take fees
for extracurricular activities that she
probably doesn't know about lynn doesn't
react but realizes he might be telling
the truth so when she returns home she
goes through her father's drawer and
sees that he has paid the school a total
of two hundred thousand baht as a
maintenance fee this makes her realize
that full scholarship is just a
publicity stunt for the school and they
still make money from all their students
lin quickly calls pat and asks if there
are more people willing to pay her like
him the following day pat arranges a
meeting with lynn grace and his rich
friends who all need lin's help she asks
all of them for 30 000 baht to help them
cheat for one semester they will have to
pay pat who will in turn give the money
to lynn so there is no proof of payment
but since there are many people passing
answers on erasers would be too risky
hence lynn comes out with another plan
she remembers there is a clock on the
front wall that is visible to everyone
she declares that the minute hand on the
wall is the number of the question they
are on similarly since the questions are
multiple choice they will have four
options the second hand on the clock
will be the answer so if the answer is
letter a lin will raise her hand when
the second hand reaches one if the
answer is b she will raise her hand when
it reaches 2 and so on the exam will be
held for 2 hours and there will be 60
questions in total which means lynn will
have to complete hers in an hour and
dedicate the next hour to help the
others the test goes exactly as they had
planned but midway bank who is sitting
right next to lynn asks her to stop
moving so much because he cannot
concentrate suddenly he drops a piece of
paper on the floor that the teacher sees
she takes the paper from him believing
it is a cheat but it turns out to be the
list of customers addresses from his
laundry she then urges him to bring
everything out of his pockets but a
tired bank accidentally pukes on his
paper everyone in the class laughs at
him as he rushes to the washroom in the
evening lynn goes to bank's home telling
him that she doesn't need the
scholarship anymore so she is giving it
back to him a surprised bank asks her
why but lynne hides the fact that she
earned enough money from helping her
friends cheat instead she says that her
father won the lottery bank happily
offers to do her laundry for free as a
thank you gift he then tags along to
take her home by bus the episode ends as
he says he wants to be friends with lynn
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on the notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching